Und ich bin sehr gespannt, ob du sie alle erkennen kannst.
Wenn dir jetzt ein Freund auf dich zukommt und dich fragt, was er sich für einen Computer kaufen soll, was sagst du dann?
Ein Grün.
Ja, das Wichtigste ist erstmal, was will er damit machen? Also sprich, wenn er jetzt irgendwelche Zocker-Games machen will, okay, soll er sich eine Windows-Maschine kaufen? Wenn er damit tatsächlich arbeiten will, sprich einen schnelleren Workflow will, dann soll er sich einen Mac kaufen. Oder erst recht dann, wenn er keinen Bock hat, irgendwie Samstag Nacht irgendwelche Treiber oder irgendwelchen Mist zu installieren und obendrein noch eine Freundin hat, dann ist er mit Windows schlecht bedient.
Kompliment für die Argumentation.
Also, das ist so der Thema und deswegen die Sache auch mit den Festplatten. Und man darf auch nicht vergessen, dass es da zwei konkurrierende Systeme gibt, wo natürlich auch mit Absicht teilweise, beispielsweise bei iTunes in neuen Windows-Versionen es Probleme gab, dass speziell die Apple-Software dann irgendwo nicht ließ. Wobei das natürlich auch doof ist, weil als die neuen iTunes-Versionen rauskamen, auf der Betriebssystemwächse bei Microsoft anstand, dass es natürlich Inkompatibilitäten gab. Das ist ja logisch. Aber zum Beispiel, die meisten Leute benutzen Photoshop zur Verwaltung oder zur Bearbeitung ihrer Fotos. Wenn man sich jetzt mal anguckt, was man tatsächlich benötigt, also sprich das Wecksortieren oder Verwalten einfach von Bildern, die man mit einer einfachen Digitalkamera, die du bei Schlecker oder so gekauft hast, das macht einmal mit iPhoto und dann macht man mit Alternativprogrammen, die du in der Windows-Base bekommst, da kriegst du Nervenzusammenbruch oder sei es drum, dass du eine Foto-CD brennen möchtest, die dann nicht auf den beliebigen DVD-Spieler am Fernseher wiedergegeben wird.
Bernd, wir halten fest von deiner Akkumentation als Zusammenfassung, weil jetzt rumpelt hier auch ein bisschen in der Telefonleiste, es prüfe sich, wer sich binden will vorher, was er denn genau haben möchte.
Ja, wobei auf der anderen Seite, du musst es ja nicht mal mehr prüfen, weil du kannst ja, wenn du unbedingt drauf abkehrst, kannst du ja auf den aktuellen Mac Windows jederzeit voll betriebsfähig starten.
Und da ist der Unterschied zu einer dann für die Ewigkeit geschlossenen Ehe. Bernd, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf.
Ich danke euch und noch viel Spaß.
Chaos Radio Teil 126, ihr seid im Blue Moon auf Fritz. Wir haben noch eine knappe Stunde Zeit, reden über Mac OS, die Vor- und Nachteile, die dieses System bietet. Wir haben gerade von Tim und von Pavel vom Chaos Computer Club eine sehr ausführliche und höchst interessante Einführung in die Geschichte von dem Betriebssystem Mac OS bekommen und haben jetzt eine Menge Anrufer, die sich zu den unterschiedlichen Betriebssystemen äußern werden. Eben gerade hatten wir Bernd dran, der eine doch sehr gerade ausargumentierte, flammende Rede auf den Mac gehalten hat. Jetzt am Telefon ist Peter, der gegenteiliger Meinung zu Bernd ist. Name, Peter.
Ja, hallo.
Grüß dich, von wo rufst du an?
Aus Berlin.
Welchen Rechner benutzt du?
Ich benutze so ideas. Also das geht los halt von Zahn bis über irgendwas. Also je nachdem wo ich, wo ich vor welcher Kiste ich halt im Endeffekt sitze. Also ich sag mal so, jedes System hat seine Vor- und Nachteile und Fakt ist einfach eins, meiner Meinung nach, also die letzte Version vom vom OS X halt an sich ist absoluter Schrot. Also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, das ist genauso überladen, dass es halt einfach mal, der wird nicht mehr schmal gedacht, sondern halt wirklich schmal fabriziert, beziehungsweise programmiert. Das ist absolut daneben. So viele Bugs gab es halt bei OS X, also beziehungsweise bei Mac halt noch nie.
Kannst du da mal ein Beispiel um die Ecke kommen?
Mit einem Beispiel um die Ecke kommen, zum Beispiel, ich war mal, irgendwann mal beim Kunden halt unterwegs gewesen, der hat sich ein super X- System halt geholt und super toll mit den DanceGuardian und so weiter und so fort, Problem war gewesen, dass er im Grunde genommen mit einer super tollen grafischen Oberfläche gearbeitet hat und so weiter, wollte mir erzählen, wie toll die ganze Geschichte ist. Fakt war einfach mal eingewiesen, dass zum Beispiel bei den DanceGuardian halt auf der grafischen Oberfläche halt Buttons halt da waren, die halt nur reine Dummies halt waren, die haben im Grunde genommen halt nicht wirklich eine Funktion halt ausüben. Das hab ich halt irgendwie dann mal mehr oder weniger halt in wirkliche Konsole halt dann fixen müssen und ich fand das halt einfach mal absolut grauenhaft mit wieviel, also wieso man im Grunde genommen halt einfach diese ganze Geschichte halt einfach insofern halt hyped, dass man sagt OS X und Linux und flalala.
Klang aber jetzt nicht nach einem besonders katastrophalen Fehler.
Ich hab kein Wort verstanden. DanceGuardian, keine Ahnung. Kannst du das übersetzen, Tim?
Ich noch nicht.
Okay, Peter, wir müssen noch weiter zuhören. Wir verstehen noch nicht so richtig, worum es geht.
Also ich bin der Meinung, dass zum Beispiel halt einfach mal diese OS X Geschichte an sich insofern überladen ist, dass man mehr und mehr auf die grafische Geschichte halt in Wert legt und im Endeffekt halt einfach auch mal vergisst, dass.
Du bist jetzt aus der Kommandozeilenfraktion, ja?
Ja, nein, also so will ich das auch nicht sagen. Auf keinen Fall. Ich sag mal so, jedes System, ich bin halt absolut der Meinung, dass jedes System seine Vorteile hat, aber halt auch viele Nachteile in der Entwicklung.
Da sind wir aber völlig einer Meinung. Da sind wir völlig einer Meinung. Das mag sich vielleicht jetzt alles so ein bisschen angehört haben, dass jetzt irgendwie der Macintosh das Tollste ist. Das wollten wir damit nicht sagen, aber wir wollten auf jeden Fall erst mal klar machen, es gibt eine ganze Menge Leute, die mit diesem System eine Menge coole Sachen hinkriegen und das stellt sich einfach wenig in den Weg und es ist eine Alternative. Und wie man nun das eine oder andere findet, das hängt natürlich auch immer ein bisschen davon ab, was man macht. Du hast ja XServe erwähnt, das ist Server-Anwendung, das ist definitiv eine der Schwächen von Apple, wo sie auch noch relativ neu sind in dem Markt und damit sie auch selber nicht besonders angeben. Obwohl ich da auch gute Erfahrungen gesammelt habe, aber das ist jetzt auch erstmal nicht so wichtig. Was ich sagen wollte ist, du sagtest ja eben auch so, naja, da muss ich das dann irgendwie auf der Kommandozeile fixen, wenn ich die richtig verstanden habe. Ja, das geht, das ist schon mal ganz gut.
Also die Kommandozeile ist sehr ordentlich. Das ist auch ein großer Vorteil von OS X. Man hat halt dieses ganze Linux noch unten drunter. Das heißt, das ganze UNIX wollte ich sagen. Also die ganze UNIX-Umgebung und der große Vorteil ist, man hat auch eine sehr große Auswahl an Open Source-Software. Also die Open Source-Welt ist einem auch weitgehend zugänglich. Das heißt, wenn man unterwegs ist, man findet sehr viel Software, die sich vor allem unkompliziert installieren lässt. Linux hat so ein bisschen das Problem, dass man sehr viel Zeit immer noch reinstecken muss, um wirklich sein System auf der Höhe zu halten und doch sehr viel schrauben. Also Linux ist immer noch nicht unkompliziert.
Ja, das Ding ist halt einfach, da gibt es halt unterschiedliche Distributionen und von daher muss man auch viele Sachen halten.
Ja, aber es gibt keine Distribution, die einfach so funktioniert und einfach auch alles kann. Das fängt an mit den fehlenden Media-Playern unter Linux, die ich mir erstmal nachholen und eigentlich alles selber durch compilen muss, weil aus rechtlichen Gründen viele Dinge nicht gehen. Ich nutze alle drei Betriebssysteme. Ich kenne sie ganz gut und es gibt Stärken und Schwächen. Da gebe ich dir vollkommen recht. Aber wenn man jetzt mal guckt all around, was ist jetzt aus meiner Sicht das unterm Strich für meine private Nutzung, für das Lesen von Mails?
Ich nehme halt einfach die älteren Distributionen von OS. Im Grunde genommen fand ich die älteren Versionen einfach stabiler.
Es wird nicht besser. Das gilt aber für alle Plattformen. Neulich gab es diesen netten Shootout Mac Plus von 1986, 1987 ungefähr gegen ein aktuelles AMD Doppelkernsystem. Dann hat man halt geguckt, wie lange dauert es booten, bestimmte Dinge in Word zu starten, Excel zu starten und die Dinge. Da hat halt der 20 Jahre alte Mac Plus knapp, zwar aber in allen Disziplinen eigentlich mit einem hundertstel fast an Ram und Rechenleistung war er schneller bei diesen praktischen Aufgaben.
Um das vielleicht ins Normalspräch zu übersetzen, das ist in etwa vergleichbar, wenn man ein altes Auto hat, eine Glühbirne wechseln will, machst die Motorhaube auf, wechselt die Birne fertig, wenn du ein neues Auto hast, musst du in der Werkstatt, weil sie müssen den Motor rausnehmen.
Ich habe aber auch lieber jetzt einen aktuellen Van als ein VW-Variant aus den 70er Jahren. Es kann ja sein, dass da die Zündung schneller gestartet ist, aber am Ende war der Komfort doch ein anderer.
Das ist jetzt auch wirklich extrem, also wieder so sehr viel Detail geprökelt.
Also mit der Diskussion kommen wir jetzt...
Nee, nicht wirklich.
Peter, ich verstehe das vollkommen. Das ist auch immer so eine Frage der Wahrnehmung. Sicherlich Mac OS X 3 kam mir auch ein bisschen geschmeidiger vor, aber wenn ich mir das Feature Set von der aktuellen Mac OS X Version anschaue, ich würde ja nicht wieder zurückgehen wollen. Und das sind kleine Schwankungen im Universum.
Ja und nein, also wie gesagt, ich persönlich bin der Meinung, dass das definitiv zu viel ist. Aber noch mal eine andere Geschichte, ganz am Rande in Bezug auf den Paragraph 202C. Da würde mich mal eure Meinung dazu interessieren. Ihr habt sicherlich mitgekriegt, was die letzte Zeit durch die Medien ging.
Aber wir haben nur zwei Stunden und wollen echt beim Thema bleiben, weil wenn wir da jetzt das Fass aufmachen, dann sind wir ganz unvergesslich.
Wir haben aber auch, wenn du auf die CCC-Seite guckst, direkt vorne als erstes der Disclaimer dazu. Also wir haben eine Menge, glaube ich, auch Presseerklärungen abgegeben und eigentlich eine ganz klare Meinung dazu, dass dort der Gesetzgeber...
Peter, pass auf.
ist der Gesetzgeber ziemlich...
Die Frage, die sich daraus herstellt, ist grundsätzlich...
Ich unterbreche dich genau jetzt, weil das ist eine andere Baustelle, die klären wir, aber nicht hier und nicht heute.
Gerade in Bezug auf Mac und andere Derivate, die irgendwie UNIX, Linux, ähnlich oder was auch immer... Im Grunde genommen, die Bordtools, die mit dabei sind, sind ja im Grunde genommen nach dem...
Darauf jetzt sehen aus.
eigentlich nichtig, oder?
Das steht aber nur so im Gesetz. Diejenigen, die die Gesetze gemacht haben, behaupten, sie hätten was ganz anderes gemeint, als das, was da drin steht. Das heißt, wir können nichts anderes als uns angucken, abwarten, was da am Ende bei rauskommt.
Bevor wir jetzt noch erläutern müssen, was der Paragraph 212c ist, es führt jetzt echt zu weit. Oder 202c. Peter, sorry, aber das machen wir an einer anderen Stelle, okay?
Tschüss. Ja, muss man mal einen Podcast nachschieben.
Vielleicht jetzt nur für Interesse. Kann man das in einem Halbsatz zusammenfassen, was das ist?
Verbot von Hacker Tools.
Es ist eine Gesetzesnovelle, eine sehr böse. Und wer auf www.ccc.de sieht, dass das Internet per Deklaration eine Blümchenwiese geworden ist. Und alles ist gut, weil es kann nichts mehr passieren, denn das Böse wurde jetzt endgültig verboten. Nach dem Waldsterben jetzt auch Hacker Tools.
Guten Abend Andreas.
Hallo, ich bin aus Pankow.
Grüß dich.
Und ich bin Mac User seit 1987. Angefangen mit Mac Plus.
Das war die Übermaschine, die wir gerade angesprochen haben.
Ja, ich habe auch fast alle Rechner aufgehoben, zum Glück. Ich bin jetzt aktuell bei Macbook Pro. Und was ich eigentlich nur sagen will, ist, ich arbeite im Designbereich und deshalb natürlich mit dem Mac, weil der einfach schöner aussieht und das mit dem Programm besser flutscht und die Ikonen und alles ist halt konsistent und einheitlich und nicht so wahnsinnig vielfältig wie bei Windows-Software. Das ist ja oft so, dass bei vielen Programmen haben sie eine ganz eigene Bildsprache bei den Menüs und Ikonen. Das fand ich halt immer ziemlich doof. Und die meisten Designer, die ich kenne, finden es auch doof. Und eigentlich ist es ja so, mit den neuen Dingern kann man ja eben auch mit Bootcamp Windows laufen lassen. Und gerade im Designbereich, im 3D-Bereich, da gibt es halt auf dem Mac keine professionelle Software. Und jetzt kann ich mit meinem Mac arbeiten. Und wenn ich halt ein Windows-Programm brauche, kann ich den eben als Windows-Rechner hochfahren und kann ganz prima mit Windows arbeiten. Und das flutscht wunderbar.
Welche Software meinst du dann, die du nicht benutzen kannst?
Ja, zum Beispiel Software wie Alias AutoStudio oder ProEngineer oder Cartier. So Programme aus dem Auto-Konstruktionen.
Okay, aber Maya grundsätzlich geht. Aber stimmt, die Spezialversion geht hier nicht?
Ja, also richtige Produktdesign oder Architektur, Software-Felixplanung und so. Das gibt es halt nach wie vor. Das gibt es halt nicht. Das kommt eben dann vor, dann muss ich den Rechner neu starten und eine Weile Windows ertragen. Aber es läuft eben wunderbar. Und das finde ich eigentlich eine tolle Sache.
Aber Parallels kann ich wirklich nur empfehlen. Jetzt in der letzten Version geht auch 3D ganz ordentlich. Und es ist wirklich eine echte Erleichterung, wenn man nicht umbooten muss. Und das performt ganz ordentlich und ist wunderbar. Also lohnt sich.
Also auch mit dieser 3D-Software? Das habe ich jetzt noch nicht ausprobiert.
Es geht erst seit zwei Wochen oder so.
Aber ich kenne das eben auch von vielen. Also ich hatte bis vor zwei Jahren hatte ich eben parallel noch ein Windows-Laptop für diese ganzen Sachen. So ein hässliches Fujitsu Siemens X-RiOS Hard-File mit einer Stunde Batterielaufzeit. Und das fällt jetzt eben alles weg. Und die meisten aus der Branche, die ich kenne, die noch vorher Windows-User waren, die haben jetzt sofort den Switch gemacht, weil die eben auch mit schönen Geräten einfach arbeiten wollen, wo alles auf Software-mäßig so locker miteinander verzahnt ist. Und was ich oft finde, ist, dass eben, wenn die Leute sagen, ja, da habe ich Bugs und Command-Zahlen-Interfaces, ich habe immer nur den Rechner aus der Packung genommen, die Software gekauft, installiert und habe nie was runtergeladen. Und ich muss echt sagen, ich hatte auch schon früher mit den Apple-Rechnern nie irgendwelche Probleme, die man auch so in Zeitschriften liest. Also ich glaube, eine Menge kommt eben so an Probleme, auch weil die Leute einfach dann eben so ein bisschen rumbasteln und nicht genau wissen, was würde sich da aus dem Netz runterladen und so.
Viren zum Beispiel.
Zum Beispiel, also hatte ich nie auf der Mac-Seite ein Problem damit.
Diese alte Legende, dass Macs weniger anfällig sind für Viren, also nicht Legende, das ist ja eine Tatsache, als Windows-Systeme. Wie ist denn das jetzt mit dem neuen Intel-Prozessor? Hat sich da was verändert mit der Systemsicherheit und der Systemperformance?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Das ist noch nicht unbedingt geklärt. Grundsätzlich kann man sagen, dadurch, dass sie auf Intel gegangen sind, sind sie jetzt ein bisschen... Ach so, haben wir den Andreas noch in der Leitung? Ja, alles klar. Ja, ich würde sagen, erstmal danke.
Wir haben dich jetzt erstmal verarzelt Andreas, oder?
Ich wollte mal kurz darauf eingehen, mit der Sicherheit, weil die Frage war ja auch im Wiki. Also, es gibt ja eine lange und breite Diskussion mit Viren und generell mit Sicherheit. Wobei Sicherheit ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr weites Feld und hat auch sehr viel mit Prozessen und nicht nur so sehr mit Zuständen zu tun. Auf jeden Fall, derzeit ist es einfach so, es gibt keinen bekannten, wirklich in der Wildbahn umherstreifenden Virus für den Mac. Was eine ganz beeindruckende Zahl ist in Anbetracht der aber tausenden Viren, die es halt in der Windows Welt gibt. Das heißt aber nicht, dass es keine bekannten Sicherheitslücken gibt. Und schon gar nicht, dass es keine unbekannten Sicherheitslücken gibt. Ich bin mir sogar sehr sicher, dass es die gibt. Es kann vor allem auch eine ganze Menge geben, die noch nicht gefunden worden sind. Ob die jetzt gefunden werden und ob die dann auch entsprechend von dieser Virenszene so ausgenutzt werden und ob Apple da in der Lage ist, was dagegen zu tun, wenn es denn mal soweit ist, kann ich nicht beantworten. Tatsache ist, derzeit sieht es noch ganz gut aus. Allerdings, jetzt mit der Intel-Plattform ist die Zahl der Experten, die solche Fehler ausnutzen können, natürlich signifikant gestiegen. Weil die Leute wissen halt einfach bei Intel deutlich besser Bescheid. Der PowerPC-Prozessor, den sie vorher verwendet haben, war in gewisser Hinsicht auch so ein Schutz. So wie wenn man in ein anderes Land kommt, da wird eine andere Sprache gesprochen, da kann man die Leute jetzt nicht gleich zu irgendwelchen Trickbetrügereien überreden. Und das muss ich jetzt zeigen. Auf der anderen Seite, Apple weiß, dass es sowas gibt, wie Sicherheit. Und Mac OS X hat auch in dem aktuellen System immerhin so etwas wie eine Security-Architektur, die sehr umfangreich ist. Das geht sehr weit. Schon immer gab es sowas wie einen Schlüsselbund-Manager, sodass ich alle meine Passwörter in einer verschlüsselten Datei ablegen kann. Und jedes Programm, was ich benutze, Web-Browser, Mail-Programme usw. legen die dort ab, sodass ich mit einem Schlüssel alles verschlüsseln kann und diese Datei wirklich verschlüsselt ist. Wenn ich mir einen Firefox installiere, nur mal so als Beispiel, das ist einmal so ein glorios gelobter Browser, der speichert dann die Passwörter für die Website, wenn ich sage, speichere mal in irgendeine Datei, in irgendeinem Format und ich habe keine Ahnung wo und ich habe keine Ahnung wie und vor allem habe ich keine definierte Methode darauf zuzugreifen. Mit diesem zentralen Schlüsselbund, was alle anderen Programme benutzen auf dem Mac, kann ich auch sehr gut meine eigenen Passwörter wieder nachschlagen, wenn ich es mal vergessen habe. Das ist sehr praktisch. Was aber noch viel wichtiger ist, ist, dass an der Stelle nicht nur in eine Datei geschrieben wird, sondern das Betriebssystem bietet auch das gesamte User-Interface zur Verwaltung dieser Sachen. Das heißt, das Speichern eines Schlüssels in dieses Schlüsselbund ist in jedem Programm identisch. Es verhält sich immer auf dieselbe Art und Weise. Es kommt immer derselbe Dialog und der sagt, Programm XY möchte jetzt gerne diese Information da reinschreiben. Ist das okay? Oder dieses Programm möchte es rauslesen. Ist das okay? Das ist das, was ich vorhin meinte mit, bei Mac OS X ist immer sehr viel mehr drin und die Benutzung ist nämlich meistens auch drin. Die Programme vererben das automatisch.
Aber ich würde sagen, trotzdem, dass aus technischer Sicht OS X nicht per se sicherer ist als jetzt Linux oder Windows. Es ist halt nur so, dass man vielleicht vielleicht auch als Schweizer in manchen Ländern unbedenklicher unterwegs sein kann als als Amerikaner. Das ist halt auch ein ähnlicher Effekt. Man wird halt eher ignoriert. Die Bedrohung ist einfach immer noch nicht da. Aber das kann sich natürlich ändern.
Wir kommen jetzt zu Thomas. Der hat eine technische Frage. Ich glaube, die geht an die Adresse von Pavel. Name Thomas. Von wo rufst du an? Aus Hannover, grüß dich.
Ja, ich habe mal eine Frage und zwar von der anderen Seite. Und zwar von der Seite des Programmierers. Da hätte ich gerne das hier mal so ein bisschen erzählt, wie es aussieht, wie einfach der Programmierer programmieren kann. Ob zum Beispiel der UNIX-Entwickler leichter reinfindet in Mac oder der Windows-Programmierer. Also ich selber habe noch nicht mit Mac programmiert. Daher wird mich das interessieren.
Machst du das professionell?
Was professionell?
Programmieren ist irgendwie dein Broterwerb oder machst du das nebenbei?
Also momentan studiere ich es und das wird dann wohl auch mein Broterwerb werden. Genau. Ja und da interessiert mich halt hier. Ich habe hier gelesen von Developer Tools, die dabei sind, die es halt einfach machen sollen, dass man unter Mac OS X programmiert. Ja, ist es dann mehr so für Anfänger gedacht? Oder wie finden sich auch Profis zurecht? Wie kompatibel ist denn die Programmierung zu den anderen Betriebssystemen?
Ja, also zunächst einmal kann man sagen, wenn du einen Mac OS X erwirbst, entweder mit dem Rechner oder separat, dann sind die kompletten Entwicklungswerkzeuge dabei. Es fehlt nichts. Du hast die vollständige Entwicklungsumgebung, du musst nichts dazu kaufen. UNIX-typisch, vielleicht eher Windows-typisch, weil es halt eine komplette IDE ist, mit Debugger und Source-Verwaltung und so weiter.
Man hat dort halt eben den GNU-Toolchain komplett, also den GCC, aber man hat oben drauf durchaus eine ganz brauchbare, grafische IDE und auch der Debugger, der halt auch den GDB wrapped. Also das ist durchaus benutzbar, Performance-Tools.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall komplett. Es gibt da nichts, was man noch dazu kaufen muss.
Was jetzt die APIs angeht, also das war eigentlich, kann man sagen, fast eine Schwäche des Mac auch von Anfang an, oder der Vorteil, dass das alles, dass das Betriebssystem sehr viel umfasst, heißt auch, dass die API sehr, sehr mächtig ist. Das ist dann auch oft eine Hürde, also wenn man wirklich jetzt komplett nativ...
Jetzt bist du aber bei dem alten Mac.
Na, es gibt mehrere, es gibt auch, man muss sich dann erstmal entscheiden, auf welcher Ebene man unterwegs sein will und wie man programmieren will. Also es gibt auch sehr viele verschiedene Arten. Wenn man jetzt einfach nur auf der Kommando-Zeile, man kann auch ganz normal eben beliebige UNIX-Programme natürlich schreiben und benutzen. Es gibt auch X-Windows, das ist allerdings...
Ja gut, aber das ist ja nicht das, was wir haben. Du willst auch darauf hinaus, die Anwendung für den Mac, die aussehen, wie sie auf dem Mac zu sein haben.
Genau, also die Frage an mich, die Frage von mir ist auch so, diese Aquaoberfläche, wenn ich jetzt für die Aquaoberfläche programmiere, sodass meine Programme sich da auch einbinden, wie flexibel bin ich da noch im Gegensatz, also im Vergleich zu den anderen Betriebssystemen? Ob es da eine Möglichkeit gibt, dass man immer noch eine Applikation schreiben kann, die mehrere Betriebssysteme bedient.
Okay, das ist nochmal ein anderer Aspekt. Da sag ich gleich mal davor, das ist nicht so einfach. Das liegt einfach da drin, dass der wesentliche Unterschied vom Mac zu den anderen Betriebssystemen ist, dass das mit der Programmierung ganz anders geht. Das kann man jetzt als Vorteil oder als Nachteil werten. Der Nachteil ist natürlich, du hast nicht mal eben eine Anwendung, die du auf alle anderen Betriebssysteme werfen kannst. Der Vorteil ist, du kannst auch alles, was auf dem Mac existiert, was bei den anderen nicht da ist, gleich nutzen, ohne großen Aufwand zu treiben. Also ich habe, ich programmiere keine Anwendungen auf Mac, also zumindest keine GUI-Anwendungen. Ich habe nur ein bisschen damit rumgespielt. Ich kenne Leute allerdings, die das tun. Ich habe in 10 Minuten ohne eine Zeile Programmcode zu schreiben, nur mit der IDE durch das Verknüpfen der vorhandenen Funktionalitäten einen Webbrowser erstellt. Programmieren möchte ich an der Stelle nicht reden. Warum erwähne ich das? Das heißt, alles basiert zunächst einmal darauf, dass du schon so eine Grundfunktionalität hast in den sogenannten Frameworks. Und du fügst dann nur noch das hinzu, was sozusagen diese Frameworks nicht haben. Und damit hast du das ganze verhalten. Diese Anwendung hatte alles. Es hatte irgendwie einen Icon, ich habe das gestartet, dann hat es eine Menüzeile gehabt, es hat ein Fenster aufgemacht, ich konnte oben irgendwie eine URL eingeben, Return drücken und dann hat es mir die Webseite angezeigt.
Also dieses Objective, also es gibt auch, ich sag mal, zwei verschiedene Apis im Prinzip, die wichtig sind, wenn man nativ unterwegs ist, nämlich Carbon und Cocoa. Cocoa ist mehr so der Objective-C Ansatz. Das heißt, das ist schon etwas gewöhnungsbedürftig, aber auf jeden Fall auch durchaus mächtig, aber wie gesagt, gewöhnungsbedürftig. Während Carbon dieselbe Funktion, oder nicht die, ja doch den Großteil der Funktionalität auch bereitstellt, der teilweise unten drunter auch sitzt und mehr so eine klassische C Funktionsapi ist. Aber beide sind so, wo man nicht rumkommt, ist wirklich, ja, sich durch Tausende von Api-Funktionen erst mal zumindest sich drauf zu schaffen, zu wissen, dass es sie gibt. Wenn man einmal, wenn man das Ganze im Griff haben will. Also es ist schon so, dass die Lernkurve für Mac-Programmierung durchaus nicht gering ist. Aber das gilt, ich meine, wenn man sich.NET oder die Win32-Api oder gar irgendwie jetzt Programme für KDE oder GNOME schreiben will, ist das nicht viel anders. Die sind aber, ja.
Darf ich dir wieder schreiben? Also, ich will es nochmal von der anderen Seite aufrollen. Das ist vor allem erstmal eine Frage der Programmiersprachen. Apple setzt ganz erheblich auf eine Programmiersprache, die sie mal selbst erfunden haben, nämlich Objective-C. Das ist eine Erweiterung der Programmiersprache C um objektorientierte Features, aber nicht so wie C++ das macht, sondern dort wurde im Wesentlichen die Funktionalität von Smalltalk kopiert. Das ist so ein Klassiker der objektorientierten Programmiersprachen. Ob das denn gut ist oder nicht, sei mal dahingestellt, ein Großteil der Anwendungen, die auf Mac kommen, sind in dieser Programmiersprache programmiert. Und es sind meistens die, die sich besonders elegant bedienen lassen. Dieses Carbon-Interface, was Paul erwähnt hat, das ist im Prinzip der Ballast von dem alten Mac OS. Das ist die alte Programmierung. Damit kann man dann auch mit C++ programmieren. Aber es gibt mittlerweile auch Möglichkeiten, mit Python vollständige Mac-Anwendungen zu machen. Und ich glaube, für Ruby gibt es mittlerweile auch etwas. Also es gibt schon eine gewisse Auswahl. Aber, um realistisch zu sein, wenn man coole Anwendungen machen will, dann ist eigentlich der Weg, den man gehen will, mit Objective-C zu arbeiten. Das mag nicht jeder. Und das ist auch noch mal so eine Diskussion für sich, ob es wertvoll ist, sozusagen da so eine Einschränkung in der Wahl der Programmiersprachen zu haben. Aber auf der anderen Seite kann man eben mit Objective-C, mit diesen Frameworks, wenn man wirklich mit dem Standard Cocoa API programmiert, sehr schnell, sehr einfach Anwendungen machen, weil man eben nicht 1000 APIs kennen muss.
Also die, ich kann nur... Was?
Warte mal, Thomas, kannst du bis hierhin folgen? Ja klar. Alles klar, fantastisch. Für alle anderen, die jetzt immer denken, was ist hier API, Gnu, GUI-Anwendung, IDE, wie auch immer, das ist das Chaos Radio, das hört ihr auf Fritz, es ist Teil 126, wir reden über Mac OS.
Kann ich noch was sagen?
Eins noch, weil wir stehen kurz vor der Tür der Nachrichten.
Ich wollte kurz noch was zusammenfassen, wenn ich kann. Also kann man quasi sagen, wenn man Betriebssystem übergreifend programmieren will, muss man sich an die vorhandenen Sachen halten, sowas wie Java, STK und solche, also verschiedene Sachen, die sowieso unter allen drei laufen.
Ja, Java geht gut, GTK geht gut.
Aber wenn man sowas wie so ein Betriebssystem übergreifender API, dass die integriert wird in diese Aqua-Oberfläche, dass zum Beispiel die Aqua-Oberfläche sagt, ich erkenne diese API an und übersetze das quasi in das Äquivalent, sodass es in diesen Stil mit hineinpasst, den ich für meinen Desktop angelegt habe, das gibt es noch nicht.
Nein, in der Form, wie...
Weil das wäre ja schön, so ein Standard für alle Betriebssysteme zu haben.
Ja, aber davon träumen sie ja nun schon alle lange Zeit. Und was ist bisher dabei rausgekommen?
Aber ich kann vielleicht einen Satz zum Abschluss noch, wie das Leben so als Mac-Programmierer ist. Also man bewegt sich in einer recht großen Nische. Und man, ja, da kann man, weil es eben, es gibt nicht so viele Mac-Programmierer wie für die anderen Plattformen. Das heißt, man kann sich das da in der Nische auch ganz gemütlich machen, wenn man da reingeht. Und wie gesagt, 6% installierte Basis. Das ist enorm, wenn man sich überlegt, dass es sich nur um die Geräte eines Herstellers handelt. Das ist schon ziemlich viel, was man da an Leuten erreichen kann.
Dann wünschen wir dir hiermit, lieber Thomas in Hannover, das Beste für deine berufliche Zukunft. Drücken die Daumen, dass das toll wird. Und solltest du den zweiten Porsche kaufen, fahren wir bitte einmal mit Probe.
Ja, Dankeschön.
Schönen Abend noch.
Was ist das? Tagsüber Fußball und Abends Konzerte. Fritz präsentiert den Berle Cup in Spremberg.
Tagsüber mit einem Fußballturnier. Mit dabei ist das Fritz-Sockeateam.
Und ab 19 Uhr mit Michme.
Mehr Infos fritz.de Der Perle Cup.
Veranstaltet vom offenen Jugendtreff ASF. Kommenden Samstag in Spremberg.
Das schönste am Sommer in der Lausitz.
Und das hört man.
23.33 Fritz-Info.
Ein weiteres Team steigt bei der Tour de France aus. Der französische Rennstall Konfedes hört auf, weil einer seiner Fahrer, der Italiener Christian Morini, positiv aufs Testoteron getestet wurde. Der 34-Jährige wurde heute kurz nach der Ziele-Einfahrt verhaftet. Und vor wenigen Minuten wurde bekannt, dass der Träger des gelben Trikots Michael Rasmussen die Tour de France verlässt. Weitere Einzelheiten sind noch nicht bekannt. Mehr dazu in einer Stunde und morgen früh ausführlich bei den Radio-Fritzern. Die vermeintliche Entführung eines deutschen Journalisten in Afghanistan hat für Verwirrung gesorgt. Jetzt scheint klar, es handelt sich um einen dänischen Reporter afghanischer Abstammung. Der Mann konnte den Geise, den man in letzter Minute entkommen. Im Streit um mehr Geld haben die Lokführer mit ihrer Urabstimmung begonnen. Die Gewerkschaft rechnet damit, dass ihre Mitglieder mit großer Mehrheit für einen Streik stimmen. Seit heute bekämpfen sich beide Seiten auch vor Gericht. Die Bahn will Streiks verbieten lassen. Die Lokführer gehen gegen Einschüchterungsversuche der Bahn vor. Der FC Bayern München hat zum siebten Mal das Finale um den Liga-Pokal erreicht. Der Rekord-Champion besiegt im Halbfinale den ersatzgeschwächten deutschen Meister VfB Stuttgart mit 2 zu 0. A10 südlicher Berliner Ring, Dreik Spree auch Richtung Schönefelder Kreuz. Zwischen Königsbüsterhausen und dem Schönefelder Kreuz gibt es Gefahr durch eine ungesicherte Unfallstelle. Der linke Fahrstreifen ist blockiert und es sind Personen auf der Fahrbahn. Und A13 Schönefelder Kreuz Richtung Dresden. Zwischen Ruhland und Ortrand ein schwerer Unfall. Die linke Spur ist gesperrt. Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 102, 6, dann Fritz in Berlin.
2 Sprechstunden.
Die Beatstacks cut off the top. Fritz, Chaos Radio hört ihr Teil 126. Es geht heute um Mac OS X. Im Studio sind immer noch Tim und Pavel vom Chaos Computer Club und am Telefon ist Ralf aus Chemnitz. Grüß dich Ralf.
Ja, also noch ein kurzer Vorbemerkung zum Vorredner. Es gibt da so was plattformübergreifendes. Das ist das QT, was beides auch ist für das KDE. Das gibt es ja auch für Mac OS, soweit ich weiß. Und das wird auch ganz gut funktionieren.
Ja, soll ich mich dazu äußern? Aber das Problem ist, es ist ein Dilemma. Wenn etwas cross-plattform ist, dann muss es sozusagen überall genauso funktionieren. Und das schließt aus, dass etwas, was irgendwo viel besser funktionieren könnte, besser funktioniert. Und an der Stelle bist du immer beschränkt. Software, die halt damit programmiert ist, also da gibt es ein gutes Beispiel, Google Earth, die verwenden dieses QT. Das User-Interface auf dem Mac von Google Earth ist einfach mal zum reiern. Also es ist wirklich richtig total scheiße und schlecht und mies und wirklich wie die schlechteste Windows-Software, die ich mir vorstellen kann. Und das erkaufen die sich damit. Und ich weiß nicht, ob die da wirklich einen Vorteil von haben.
Naja, es läuft immerhin. Also es ist...
Ja, es läuft, es zeigt was an, aber dafür brauchst du kein User-Interface. Ich meine, das ist eine Erde, ja, da guckt man drauf. Aber sobald du mal versuchst, da irgendwie was einzugeben, wenn man nicht mal Cut und Paste funktioniert, dazuverlässig.
Ja, in Firefox auch nicht, übrigens.
Ja, das ist auch genau derselbe Kram.
Okay, wir stellen auch hier fest, der Teufel steckt im Detail. Ralf, du hast noch eine Bemerkung zur Qualität bei Mac.
Ja, nicht, nicht zum Mac, sondern so in letzter Zeit. Also gibt es so bei Sicherheitsupdates oder irgendwelchen Updates generell, so 10.4.9 oder 10.4.10, da gab es ganz schöne Probleme. Also ich hatte den letzten fast Probleme und da hat es mir mein Mac fast ganz zerschossen. Also ich konnte dann nur noch von der Kommandoteile aus das vorherige Update einspielen, weil überhaupt keine Oberfläche mehr hochkam. Da war irgendwas, weiß ich nicht, Keychainmanager, irgendwelche Bibliotheken kaputt. Da kamen irgendwelche, der dynamische Linker, da hat irgendwelche Fehler gebracht. Also das sind irgendwelche Fehler, das finde ich schon irgendwie bedenklich. Aber ansonsten bin ich auch zwar auch sehr begeistert und merke, diese Qualität, der Update, da muss Apple, finde ich, noch ein bisschen mehr tun.
Da merkt man, dass die halt auch nur mit Wasser kochen.
Na, ich habe das jetzt gelesen, die kochen auch nur mit Wasser, aber mit sehr teuren.
Wobei, also ich muss sagen, gut, ich habe jetzt nur meine empirische ein Jahr Benutzer-Erfahrung und so irgendwelche größeren Katastrophen sind mir jetzt erspart geblieben. Ich bin so ein Intensivnutzer. Also bei mir ist das Ding 16 Stunden am Tag, sieben Tage in der Woche in Betrieb und ist eigentlich 24 Stunden am Tag in meiner Nähe. Das führe ich immer, also MacBook Pro halt. Und meistens halten, also Laptops halten wegen dieser Intensivnutzung bei mir ungefähr ein Jahr. Danach sind sie einfach durch. Die Tasten sind abgewetzt und irgendwie das klappert alles und dann kann man es zwar noch benutzen. Und bislang hält er. Also ja, ein paar Schrauben sind schon ab und so und die Tastatur glänzt auch schon ganz verdächtig, aber ansonsten. Und mit den Software-Updates muss ich sagen, das hat bisher problemlos funktioniert. Ich bin da auch mal misstrauisch, weil heutzutage schiebt einem ja jeder fast jeden Tag möchte sich irgendetwas updaten auf dem Rechner, irgendwie mal der Browser, mal irgendeine Anwendung, mal das Betriebssystem und so richtig wohl fühlt man sich natürlich nicht dabei, weil jedes Mal ist es eigentlich eine neue Software, die man hat. Und ja.
Das finde ich auch so ein bisschen manko, was Apple eben noch hat, finde ich, also bei Mac OS. Was ansonsten ja eigentlich sehr gut ist, aber bei Windows, da gibt es diesen abgesicherten Modus, wenn irgendwas zerschlossen ist, dann kann ich immer noch diesen abgesicherten Modus starten oder...
Gibt es auch beim Mac OS Shift drücken?
Ja, aber wenn ich jetzt so ein Update zum Beispiel eingespielt habe, das habe ich ja probiert gehabt, und da kam ja gar keine grafische Oberfläche mehr zu den Standen. Und da habe ich auch Shift und alle möglichen Tasten, die es da gibt, gedrückt, da kam nie wieder eine grafische Oberfläche.
Wobei das jetzt schon nach einem sehr individuellen Problem klingt.
Also beim Mac gibt es aber eigentlich mehr Möglichkeiten, sich also im Katastrophenfall angefangen von der mitgelieferten Rettungs-CD zu booten, wo man dann Zugriff hat, bis darüber, dass man das System im Target-Mode, also jetzt bei den Laptops laufen lassen kann, und von draußen auf die Festplatte zugreifen, über Firewire bis hin. Das Beste ist, was halt bei Mac viel, bei OS X viel besser funktioniert als unter Windows, dass ich von einer Kopie meiner Festplatte einfach starten kann, wenn ich sie extern dranhänge, ohne dass ich was tun muss. Das heißt, das Geheimnis, wenn man sowas verhindern will, beispielsweise Super Duper nehmen, einmal in der Woche einen Backup ziehen, und dann kann ich, wenn irgendwas passiert, einfach sogar von diesem Backup direkt booten und das wieder zurückspielen. Also eigentlich ist es einfacher, im Katastrophenfall wieder mit Mac klarzukommen.
Und falls euch das jetzt komplett zu viel ist, Tim, es gibt auch von dieser Sendung einen Podcast, wo man das alles noch mal in Ruhe nachhören kann. Und den gibt es irgendwie im Laufe der nächsten Tage, oder? Ja, und den findet man unter ccc.de.
Unter chaosradio.ccc.de.
Ja, wie dem auch sei. Ralf, dir noch einen schönen Abend im Chemnitz. chaosradio.ccc.de Aber wenn man ccc, ne, kommt man nicht, aber...
Einfach bei googelt Chaosradio eingeben.
Oder du hast einen Bookmark.
Ja, oder was auch immer.
Mac OS X ist das eigentliche Thema dieser heutigen Sendung von Chaosradio 326. Wir haben jetzt die verschiedensten Aspekte schon beleuchtet von der Wiederherstellung des Systems, über die unterschiedlichen Möglichkeiten der Programmierung bis hin zur eigentlichen Geschichte des Betriebssystems. Haben auch die Nachteile, glaube ich, in ziemlicher Ausführlichkeit behandelt. Aber es gibt noch ein paar Aspekte, die wir auf jeden Fall noch in diese Sendung packen sollten, weil sie gehören dazu.
Man könnte da so viel darüber erzählen. Mit diesen zwei Stunden kommen wir da hinten und vorne nicht zur Rande. Aber es gibt ein paar interessante Entwicklungen.
Es gibt eine neue Plattform, auf der OS X läuft.
Genau, es gibt mehrere neue Plattformen. Genau genommen ist es nur eine, du hast recht. Also Apple hat ja vor einigen Monaten neue Systeme vorgestellt, die keine Macs sind, abgesehen von den iPods. iPods gibt es ja schon länger. Aber Anfang des Jahres kamen Apple TV dazu. Wobei Apple TV eigentlich auch nichts anderes als ein abgespeckter Macintosh ist. Also eigentlich ist das so ein Mac Mini. Wobei man nicht, also nicht, ja Fern, also man kann ihn in die Ferne sehen, aber man sieht nicht das, was wir unter Fernsehen verstehen, sondern man sieht halt seine eigenen Movies, die man untergeladen oder gedownloadet oder gekauft oder per Podcast abonniert hat. Und auch da läuft Mac OS X drauf. Gut, das überrascht nicht, weil das ist im Herzen eigentlich ein Mac, aber zeigt schon mal, dass Apple da einen anderen Weg gehen wollte. Und jetzt vor ein paar Wochen ist das iPhone vorgestellt worden, ein Telefon und auch dieses Telefon läuft unter, naja, wie sie sagen, OS X oder OS X. Ich weiß gar nicht, haben sie OS X oder OS X gesagt. Ich glaube, er sagt OS X. Interessanterweise heißt es halt nur noch OS X und der Mac ist weg, weil es ist ja kein Mac, denn ein Mac ist sozusagen ein Computer, den man irgendwie durch die Gegend trägt, aber kein Telefon. Und das iPhone ist nur ein Telefon, hat auch keinen Intel Prozessor wie die Desktop-Systeme und die Laptops, sondern hat so einen typischen Spezialprozessor, der in solchen Geräten immer zu finden ist. Aber dort läuft eben im Herzen dieselbe Software. Die Oberfläche sieht allerdings total anders aus. Sehr interessant zu sehen, dass Apple es geschafft hat, ihr ein Betriebssystem so weit skalieren zu lassen, dass es eben sowohl große, dicke, fette Desktop-Maschinen und Server bedienen kann, als eben auch Telefone.
Wir haben vorhin schon mal kurz darüber gesprochen, du hast so ein Ding schon in der Hand gehabt. Wir reden jetzt nicht über Bilder, die man im Internet, im Fernsehen gesehen hat. Du hattest das Ding wirklich dabei.
Ich hatte es kurz in Bedienung. Ist der Hammer. Also ich denke, das Gerät wird einschlagen wie eine Bombe.
Obwohl es so viel Negativkritik gibt von wegen, zerkratzte Oberfläche und das läuft nur irgendwie mit dem, mit einem speziellen Provider. Es ist irgendwie so und so teuer. Du musst die Software von Dingens nutzen.
Das ist genau so.
Weißt du, wenn ich jetzt losgehe, mir ein Telefon von Firma, Telefonmüller kaufe, schiebe ich irgendeine SIM-Karte hinten rein und es funktioniert.
Die Leute wollen ja nicht SIM-Karten in ihre Telefone reinschieben, sondern sie wollen ja telefonieren. Und sie wollen ja auch nicht irgendwie... Eigentlich ist es ihnen vollkommen egal, ob sie nun bei Vodafone oder T-Mobile sind, sondern sie wollen da, wo sie einfach am wenigsten genervt werden. Das heißt, die große Frage ist, ist der Tarif, mit dem das Gerät auf den Markt kommt, okay oder nicht? Dann ist den Leuten völlig Schnurzpipp, egal, welches Logo da unter Umständen irgendwo noch mal links in der Ecke steht. Hauptsache, sie haben eine Telefonnummer und sie können anrufen und es funktioniert. Das ist eben das, was auch viele Leute nicht begreifen. Wenn das iPhone vorgestellt wurde, kann man gleich so, na ja, und es hat dies nicht und es hat das nicht und es hat dies nicht und das nicht. Ich hab mir das immer so durchgelesen und das sind so Sachen, wo einfach niemand jemand schreit. Aber dass das Ding einfach mal sowas kann wie telefonieren, das halte ich schon mal für einen großen Fortschritt.
Telefonieren kann mein Telefon auch.
Ja, meins nicht. Soweit würde ich nicht gehen, dass dieses Telefon mir wirklich das Telefonieren leicht macht. Dieses Telefon, soll ich mal über meinen Telefon ranten?
Ich auch, ich auch.
Das ist so scheiße, das ist so scheiße, es ist noch nicht mal in einer Lage, in zwei unterschiedlichen Programmen dieselbe Uhrzeit anzuzeigen.
Es ist ja auch keine Uhr, es ist ja auch ein Telefon.
Ja, aber ich meine eine Uhr. Jeder verwendet sein, man trägt heute keine Armanduhr mehr, weil man hat ein Handy. Das ist so, Leute benutzen die Uhr auf ihrem Telefon, das hat sogar Nokia begriffen. Aber wie man zwei Programme mit derselben Uhrzeit ausstattet, das scheint denen komplett fern zu sein.
Wir hatten mal einen Blue Moon zum Thema Mobiltelefon und Nutzung und da stellt sich heraus, die Leute benutzen auch keine Wecker mehr. Weil natürlich hast du dein Telefon mit einem Wecker drin. Was waren denn das für Applikationen beim iPhone, wo ihr Leute gesagt habt, das hat es nicht, das hätte ich gerne, wo du sagst, brauchst nicht oder unwichtig?
Der erste Schrei war nach UMTS. Das halte ich persönlich für kein besonders wichtiges Thema. Was die Leute eigentlich haben wollen, ist schnelles Internet. Aber schnelles Internet kann man auch mit Edge bekommen. Kurz zum Hintergrund. Telefon ist ein reines GSM-Telefon. Man kann Daten über einen Standard, der heißt Edge. Edge ist etwas, was sich derzeit noch im Ausbau befindet. Vodafone zum Beispiel führt jetzt ein Megabit Datenübertragung über Edge ein. Das sollte eigentlich jedem reichen. Keine Ahnung, ob das so kommen wird, oder ob sie nicht vielleicht doch schon UMTS einbauen. Das ist nicht das, worum sich das iPhone kümmert. Das iPhone räumt einfach mit den Problemen auf, die andere Telefone haben. Dass man sie nicht einfach benutzen kann. Ich bin nun wirklich... Gut, ich bin vielleicht doof, aber nicht blöd. Ich arbeite seit 20 Jahren mit Computern, aber mein Telefon kann ich nicht bedienen. Dieses Gerät ist nicht zu benutzen. Zwölf Untermenüs, um eine Sache einzustellen, muss ich an drei verschiedenen Orten, und ich habe es danach sofort wieder vergessen. Es geht einfach nicht, es ist nicht benutzbar.
Du hast da gerade irgendwie so ein Nokia High-End-Modell.
Latest and greatest, super teuer.
Aber mein Sony Ericsson P990i ist auch die komplette Katastrophe. Die Hardware ist in Ordnung, aber die Software ist einfach ganz, ganz schlimm. Es ist so schlimm, dass man... Telefonieren geht gerade eben, aber eigentlich schlechter als bei einem Telefon von vor 5 oder 10 Jahren. Und alles andere. Ich meine, ich verstehe auch nicht, wie große Firmen, die zig Millionen in die Entwicklung stecken, in der Lage sind, so zu versagen. Ich meine, das fängt damit an. Dieses Telefon hat 90 MB RAM. Nach dem Booten belegt das Betriebssystem 80 MB. Das heißt, ich habe noch irgendwie nach dem Booten, und das Booten dauert 1, 5 Minuten ungefähr von diesem Telefon, was schon mal eine Katastrophe für sich ist. Sobald ich eine Anwendung starte, sind die restlichen 10 MB auch weg, sodass wenn ich etwa in einer Mail... Gut, wenn ich...
Wir kommen jetzt ein bisschen vom Thema weg, glaube ich.
Du hast sonst 5 Minuten. Also ein Rent will ich noch. Ich habe das Ding, weil es hat auch WLAN natürlich, weil ich dachte, gut, jetzt kann ich dann hier demnächst meine Mails lesen. Und dann platzte, aber nachdem ich halt meinen Account eingerichtet habe, weil offenbar meine Mailfolder zu groß sind, schaffte es noch nicht mehr, die Header runterzuladen. Also das Telefon, nachdem ich auf meine Mail zugreifen wollte, war unbenutzbar, bootete nicht mehr. Ich musste es komplett löschen. So, das war das erste Ding. Denn wenn man irgendwo einen Link anklickt, dann versucht er, den Browser zu öffnen, hat aber keinen Speicher mehr, weil keine zwei Programme gleichzeitig laufen könnten. Ansonsten vergisst man das Wireless auszumachen, ist die Batterie in zwei Stunden leer und nur solche Dinge. Also es ist, ich könnte jetzt minutenlang noch, aber es ist faszinierend, wie schlecht einfach heutige sogenannte, naja, wie heißt diese Klasse von Telefons? Man nennt sie Smartphones, aber leider sind sie nicht smart. Also wie schlecht Smartphones sind. Ich bin gespannt aufs iPhone. Ich hatte es noch nicht in der Hand. So, aber was schon mal ganz gut klingt, ist, dass die Oberfläche schnell ist und snappy, wie man sagt, funktioniert und einfach man ein gutes Erlebnis hat. Also ich bin gespannt.
Es ist furchtbar sexy. Aber was das eigentlich Wichtige an dem iPhone ist, erstens dadurch, dass da halt OS X drauf ist, verspricht es noch viele Überraschungen, was gute Anwendungen betrifft. Und das, was da bisher drauf ist, funktioniert einfach sagenhaft gut. Und das andere Ding, was viele Leute nicht sehen und was auch sozusagen dieser Ruf nach, ich will meinen Provider wechseln, komplett ausschaltet, es ist das erste Telefon mit Internet. Und zwar nicht das erste Telefon, das Internet könnte, sondern das erste Telefon, was, wenn ich es in Betrieb nehme, auf jeden Fall kostenlos Internet hat. Und die Programmierung für, also wer Interesse hat, für das iPhone zu entwickeln, ist quasi gezwungen, das Web gebunden zu machen. Was erstmal alle natürlich sehr enttäuscht hat, weil die wollen natürlich auf das Gerät drauf. Das hält aber Apple erstmal zu, aus vielen nachvollziehbaren Gründen. Und haben halt gesagt, na ja, ihr könnt aber hier über das Web rangehen. Und wir haben da so ein paar Hooks eingebaut, sodass ihr das auch so aussehen lassen könnt, als wäre es eine richtig schicke iPhone-Anwendung. Also mit diesem ganzen Eyecandy, den sie hier drauf haben und diese Bedienungselemente kann man halt auch alle verwenden. Und na ja, es hat eine Woche gedauert oder ein paar Tage eigentlich nur gedauert. Und diese ganzen neuen Web 2.0-Dienste, die ja so super populär sind, was weiß ich, Flickr und so weiter, To-Do-Listen, Manager, machen halt jetzt einfach ihre speziellen Interfaces fürs iPhone, was sich relativ einfach machen lässt. Und ja, dieses Gerät existiert seit zwei Wochen und es gibt wahrscheinlich jetzt schon mehr gut zu benutzende sinnvolle Anwendungen, als auf all diesen Nokia, Motorola und Sony Ericsson-Telefonen in den letzten zehn Jahren insgesamt. Und das ist, Apple macht sich sozusagen gerade auf, allen ganz gehörig den Arsch zu versohlen.
Ich bin gespannt. Ich mein, muss natürlich auch sagen, bei allem netten Nutzererlebnis, es ist natürlich, Apple ist eine Firma, die auch an vielen Stellen doch den Daumen draufhält. Es ist eine geschlossene, proprietäre Plattform. Das Open Source geht bei Apple nur bis zu einem bestimmten Grad. Also da gibt es, also Apple und Open Source ist auch eine lange kontroverse Geschichte, die wir jetzt hier nicht ausbreiten wollen. Aber das muss auf jeden Fall noch erwähnt sein, dass natürlich man auch viele Dinge durchaus misstrauisch beäugen kann und muss. Und dass ich mir jetzt trotz allem, also auch so schön Mac OS ist, ich möchte weder auf Linux noch auf Windows verzichten müssen. Ich finde es gut, dass es diese drei Plattformen gibt. Ich nutze sie alle, aber ich nutze am meisten OS X.
Wo wir gerade bei Telefonen sind, muss man vielleicht nochmal erwähnen. Hier im Chat kommt das natürlich auch gleich wieder auf. Es gibt ja noch ein anderes interessantes Telefonprojekt, was diesen Aspekt der freien Software berücksichtigt. Das OpenMoco Projekt, das ist in aller Munde. Das ist allerdings ein Projekt, was noch sehr in den Entwicklerschuhen steht. Also derzeit gibt es zwar Telefone zu kaufen, aber eigentlich nur für Entwickler. Und wenn man sich die Software anschaut, die da draufläuft, das ist auch wirklich nicht für den End-User zumutbar. Trotzdem, das ist das erste Telefon, was wirklich vollständigen Zugriff auf alles macht. Und an der Stelle hat man im Prinzip einen direkten Vergleich. Man hat die Linux-Welt sozusagen, aber auch mit ihrem ganzen Credo in diesem einen Device zunächst einmal nur. Aber das ist eine offene Plattform, da könnten also auch noch andere kommen. Wird aber noch ein bisschen dauern. Auf der anderen Seite dieser Gegenpol mit dem iPhone, das irgendwie mit Sweet Eyecandy daherkommt und auch wirklich mit Features, die mit anderen nicht drin sind. Aber wenn man dann eben das User-Interface vergleicht, zeigt sich eben, wie diese drei Welten, Windows, der Mac und Linux, auch vollständig andere Herangehensweisen haben, wie man mit dem Computer arbeitet. Windows, das ist so diese Bürokratenwirtschaftswelt mit ihren klaren Rastern und Linien und Kästchen und die einfach es gewohnt sind, auf lange Tabellen zu starren. Bei Linux ist es einfach dieses Arkane, auch dieser Spaß, sage ich noch nicht mal im Negativen, also auch dieser Spaß an der Technik selber, die dann aber auch an allen Stellen rausquillt. Und diese Mac-Domäne ist eben einfach dieses, ich habe keinen Bock, mich mit der Technik rumzuschlagen, ich möchte einfach, dass es funktioniert und es soll auch noch schick aussehen. Und das sind, glaube ich, so die großen drei Marktsegmente, die heute Computer überhaupt bedienen.
Und das ist ein wunderbares Schlusswort, auch von Tim und Pavel vom Chaos Computer Club zu diesem heutigen Thema. Mac OS X, 10, 10, ja X, 10, 10.
War das schon Schluss oder was?
Schulz jetzt, das war das Chaos Radio 126, als Podcast nachzuhören unter chaosradio.ccc.de. Wenn ihr mehr von diesen Jungs wissen wollt, wenn ihr euch mal angucken wollt, was der Chaos Computer Club eigentlich macht, 8. bis 12. August das Camp in Niederfino, in der Nähe von Eberswalde. Ich haue es immer durcheinander. Na Schnoppel, auf jeden Fall bei Eberswalde, Finofort, Flughafen, großartige Geschichte, 8. bis 12. August. Mehr dann online unter entweder chaosradio.ccc.de oder unter fritz.de. Hier geht es jetzt weiter mit Martin Petersdorf und dem Nightfly. Wir sagen Tschüss, macht's gut und fass dich in die Steckdose.
Und voller Demut legt ich meine Schürze wieder. Und schließlich kriech ich und dann grill, um mich herum wird alles still.
Hallo, abreiten.